what up reject nation greg and john here
today we are going to watch episode
three of stranger things four so excited
for this
ladies and gentlemen as always
full-length watch long as we sync up
with the time code for stranger things
or for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon cover a whole bunch of shows
some of them with exclusive reaction
highlights included if you don't want to
do that leave a like and a comment with
your thoughts on today's episode also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next episode is up on the
channel lastly then boys at prepper when
you guys are in need of editing help
they are the boys to contact don't over
book them though because we still need
some space oh yeah but
that's a good prompt for them to have
let's do this
polarizer
back in the game
love me some paul ryzer
there were no signs of any attacker
no bruises it's as if her attacker was a
ghost
does this remind you of anything doctor
no
doesn't i've never seen a port like this
men like you who created this problem in
the first place
we need guns lots of guns
here's a photo at a roller skating rink
taken just days ago 11 is dead i'm not
convinced are you saying
i'm helping her is that what you're
saying am i getting suspiciously
defensive
i i don't know what you're talking about
why are you taking that box those are
peter's old school projects you do not
need those sam do something
come on go all nobody on them sam
i have been theorizing since the first
trailer
that paul ryder was going to die this
season oh boy i hope not
just does it seem my way it seems like
he's got to that's that's the best way
that he can
go out with dignity
angela angela do you know where you are
angela
angela who's the boss
usually the third episode he does
third time's a char
[Music]
don't worry 11 your problems are only
about to get better
i'm shedding and [ __ ] but that future
prom queen is gonna be fine i mean it
was just like rubber wheels plastic oh
prom queen
[Music]
nice little
nod building up
i mean the grand scheme of things
just a little blip
that's a funny word man
[Music]
liberty
kids like risotto
oh i make a good risotto you're just
like hey murray
so i thought hey you know what why don't
i drop in and say hello to my old
friends this thing came in you passed me
the olive oil which one turns out i have
to go to a conference tomorrow in alaska
so do eskimos like still live in igloos
or uh
like living in the
suburbs yeah
who is this
[Laughter]
this girl got smacked in the head today
at the roller rink snack it was a
plastic skate no i was like rubber
rubber rubber remember anyway she she
looks like she's gonna be fine she's
totally fine she didn't look fine oh god
[Music]
i sense tension
is it the risotto everyone hates the
risotto it's risotto he's smacking dude
i still have no idea who he
i just want is say i ship murray and
joyce all the way
team
moise
paul ryder is going to pop off her under
the bed
now these visuals are nuts
so nuts
such a nightmare
and the color scheme like oh
mr miyagi
we're gearing up preparing for the hunt
and we're not killers like eddie
and we just want to talk to him get him
to admit his crime yeah little friendly
neighborhood chat
i like side bullies
we always laugh at everything if you're
not up to this you can go home there's
no judgment
you'll still be one of us all right
because you got the winning point that's
all that keeps you as one of us
delivery service maybe you shouldn't
just burst in guys yeah serious
knock at least
so before that happens we need to find
vecna kill him and prove your innocence
that's all dustin we've actually been
through this kind of thing before i mean
they have mine was more human flesh
based and theirs was more smoke related
but
meta
[Music]
[Applause]
humor ambi lamps
oh
yeah
i thought with it
when you observe the details
like the hand and the freaking arms
you were scared of me no no
no that's not that's that's not true i
was surprised it doesn't change anything
it doesn't matter i care for you
so much but you don't you don't love me
anymore
what dude you never say it you can't
even write it mike from mike
from mike
from mike you can't let these mouth
breathers ruin you ruin us i mean
they're nobodies
and you're a superhero
tell her you love her baby
yeah
hi is uh jane hopper live here what is
this about you may or may not be aware
of an incident that happened last night
involving jane at the wrinkle mania that
was an accident just tell us where
you're taking her one of the cuffs
really necessary
ah
she being taken by and they've probably
got some higher ups yeah they're just
disguised as cops
ah the good old days why are you adults
always gone when the kids need you most
i think you did the right thing
this way what they play too much
nintendo eat too much junk food smoke
some ganja pound some beers experiment
sexually i mean
[Laughter]
thanks for opening up murray
[Music]
so as you're acting if my pilot gets the
money you will bring it to me in this
plane tomorrow
then you can hit your right with him
back to your country great so he's a
criminal well of course unless do you
want to do this job gandhi
ideally sure
you miss that plane tomorrow
i am still rich
and you're still stuck in kamchatka so
whatever it is you're planning american
let's get to it yes
i'll pull up
i like this actor
i saw chrissy leaving miss kelly's
office
if you saw a monster you wouldn't go to
the police they'd never believe you
but you might go to your shrink shrinks
are the enemy yes
scientology was right
there's just something i want to check
on first something you maybe want to
share with the rest of us i don't want
to waste your time it's a real shot in
the dark yeah okay are you out of your
mind flying solo with this vector creep
on the loose no it's too dangerous you
need
someone to
oh oh my god is it going to be dancer
gotta loop back around
us ladies we'll stick together
unless you think we need you to protect
us
i'm so sick of this woke [ __ ] yeah
take it back to season one just a little
boy's club that's it
yeah buddy
matchka
must be right on top of the creole house
so he just kind of like connects to it
like a hive mind yeah this is like his
cerebro yeah yeah like yeah
nightmare
to go to that awful place
i'll just tell them i fell again i
slipped
we're looking for eddie munson
he's in this band lukas what the hell
we're just trying to find eddie man well
you have eyes don't you he's not here
oh hey man
smash the guitar on him where is i don't
know
this is not the way to go about it send
him to kamchatka
he's calling her out looking for andy
maybe he got him where do we find this
dustin
every season needs an alpha bully yep
jane hopper
okay yes i see her now it looks like
she's still being processed okay so uh i
mean what does that mean exactly it
means they're putting her in the system
now
[Music]
chills
[Music]
this is not like maybe painful [ __ ]
hopper doesn't [ __ ] around anymore
[Music]
oh
buddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn victor creel escape from pendrist
asylum and that he's the one running
around hawkins committing all these
murders
pretty much
victor committed the eyeball murders
like way back in the 50s
59.
these murders pre-date uh 11 and the
upside down by about 30 years back to
the library could we get the keys to the
basement archives of course give me one
second
did i come off mean or condescending or
something
no
right
sorry it's just you seem annoyed
do you have a minute to talk
um yeah of course
of course here at my home
your temporary insanity earlier today
when you basically threw yourself at
nancy are you implying that i still have
a thing for nance no i'm not implying
i'm stating
[Laughter]
i was just trying to protect a friend
you're like bright red he's written no
i'm not i don't want to talk about it
i'll punch you so hard in your face that
your teeth will fall back out oh
too far
not cool sorry
oh no one wants a protective platonic
friend
that's
not true they can fend for themselves
did chrissy mention anything
you wouldn't want me talking to any
other students about you right if i were
dead and it would help catch the killer
then yeah i most definitely would
can i use the bathroom
sure
up the stairs to the left
in the attic that's where she keeps the
files
smooth
what'd she say nothing but just drive
nothing steve drive
man no one's home
so now what we keep looking
oh
where the hell is sinclair
dustin lucas where the hell have you
been just listen are you guys looking
for eddie yeah and we found him no
thanks to you you found him he's at a
boathouse uncle no
you're so behind it's ridiculous okay
just meet us at the school we'll explain
later
i can't
i think some real bad shit's about to go
down what are you talking about what bad
[ __ ]
oh guys shut the [ __ ] up never be quiet
what the hell were you
doing i was i was looking for clues
clues
what freshmen think you sherlock holmes
or something
that was funny give it here josh yeah
yeah
i found one
what
a clue a clue
don't say it i know where eddie's hiding
more than a clue mislead them bro that
is exact type of information they're
looking for that's the solution
here come the men in black
are you transporting a jane hopper yeah
what is this i'll take her off your
hands
what if this only had to do with hitting
angela yeah
this goes all the way to the top brass
oh man
[Music]
hey kiddo
welcome to alaska oh god this is spring
[Laughter]
does hopper not know there's a
demogorgon there i guess he mustn't
unless they just don't need to tell us
that right now
guys you're so cool
oh
no
oh in the cold too higher hello dr
gordon stop
oh yeah
yup yup yup
let's go full gerald's game let's just
do it
oh they got any shirt
i don't like any
level of
gloving you don't you don't want to
build the magic
i wanted to make sure
that
you knew that steve and i are just
friends
like platonic with a capital p
in case that's adding any tension
between us
[Laughter]
[Music]
may i remind you that we are looking for
information on dark wizards if someone's
gonna write about that it's gonna be
these weirdos
ah
elvis cloned by aliens
you never know
season five
how's it going huggins
according to several insiders victor
believed his house was haunted by an
ancient demon victor allegedly hired a
priest to exercise the demon from his
home pretty novel for the 50s exodus
wasn't even out yet
i mean it sounds pretty insane it just
didn't go public because the plea
bargain the records were sealed
what if a demon did invade victor's home
holy [ __ ]
founder yeah not just chrissy smile fred
was seeing miss kelly too am i next
better got a good dicer
horribly hawkins is in danger each time
it returns it comes back stronger
smarter
deadlier a war is coming to hawkins
where you at freak
ha ha
good on you lucas smarts
you sure eddie was here
yeah
i'm positive
let's check around the back
there are good people brave friends
i know it's not fair to ask more of you
but i wouldn't be here if i didn't think
this was the only way
i don't have my powers
what if
i told you there was a way
[ __ ]
why have you been holding out you're
gonna kill angela weeks again
he's gonna disintegrated her on the spot
developing the means to restore your
abilities what the hell
dude
you are proactive
but there are others
who don't believe in you
who think you are
i believe they're wrong
i believe
you're the cure
but you should know there is a very real
possibility this program fails
and if it does
you will never see your friends again
my friends
in hawkins are they in danger yeah
i'd say
[Music]
i'm afraid your friends and hawkins are
very much can i see fred's file
she's got the same symptoms
it's a lot for anyone and it's okay to
not be okay
[Music]
so you say the word and i will take you
right back home
or come with me now come with me now my
great speech
[Music]
please pack the food get the waffles for
the road
[Music]
we need you jonathan
i thought i thought he was stalking the
other guy yeah what gives
[Laughter]
i was just hap hoping it was goofy
maximilian
[Laughter]
all righty just a few more to go but 11
uprising yes 11 rising 11 2.0
fantastic speech
that riser is definitely dead yeah
yeah
yeah yeah there's no way he's gonna save
your moment like this without it coming
with any punishment
it's like the biggest most cathartic
like you know boost in uh morale yeah
man
uh but i like what they're doing with
11. it's she's her character has always
had a a struggle with accepting herself
that's a big part of her journey and the
search for identity
you know and then what if it's always
been like no just accept everything that
was kind of you were born into like what
if you can accept that and realize that
that curse has always been the gift and
the key to being a hero this whole time
the key to being a force of good that
you have to go through that to be the
force of good as opposed to like in
season two trying to shift her identity
around a lot and going down a different
path and then now here trying to just be
like super duper normal this whole thing
um that yeah it's like she has a
struggle of acceptance of who she is and
and dealing with her past
and that's something that i think can be
a cool showdown to occur with creole or
uh
vechna but
vechna vachna
that would be the ultimate twist
and pull off the mask to some swedish
guy yeah
uh that vecna and and her and you know
she has to deal with her own stuff i
thought it was a little cheesy with uh
it was like a rewarding kind of like
action hero cheese to me
like what if i told you i developed a
program yeah yeah
it's already a potion and i did this in
my 80s computer at home
it's been so dark to have a moment like
that i'm just some like cheesy montage
of already developing something it did
feel like a nice act break or something
like that because yeah everything else
has developed at a pretty uh you know
steady and deliberate pace alongside
everything else and then this was
i it's you know the answer to the
question and yeah he establishes it
could not work and things could go very
wrong okay however yes
basically this is exactly what we need
but better
so yeah i mean you'll be even stronger
yeah yeah so it does
break the reality of the moment a little
bit but yeah not in a way that that
vexed me or anything like that because
of course we want to see eleven come
back bigger and better and we know that
there will be consequences to that and
that won't be the entire solution to
everything that's going on
yeah yeah it's it's like she was born as
11
or at least raises 11
knows that her
her mom named her jane should go by the
ingenity of jane
and now it's i think it's about putting
the two together now for her yeah you
know
jalebin
yes
but yeah yeah merging both identities
and taking the things that she does have
that she has amassed of a normal life
and of real human connections but also
bruce wayne is batman batman is bruce
smith yeah but really both of them
thriving in harmony alongside each other
yeah
yeah something along those lines so that
was great paul ryser really welcomed
return here um this is more of like a
momentum forward episode you know yeah
of a lot of plot advancements
lucas being conflicted i was about to be
pissed at him when i was like oh [ __ ] is
he about to is he about to just kind of
give in to peer pressure i didn't know
where he would mislead them smart
mislead because it's also a reasonable
location where he could assume someone
was hiding out yeah
um
yeah these
bullies well not even really they have
like a bully attitude but they're not
i mean they're kind of bullies they're
gonna get up the band they have a motive
here they're trying to get revenge for
the death of the guy's girlfriend yeah
they're they're not the social outcast
bullies who are mean to everyone but
yeah yeah clearly they look down on
everybody beneath their tear up between
their athletic abilities yeah we are the
top of the food chain and we are the
gold standards
of high school a thousand percent yeah
but i really like that like i really
like the way they've drawn the conflicts
both with like lucas dealing with his
new friend group and the old friend
group and the awkwardness of navigating
that as well as like mike and eleven
like we were talking last episode about
you know not seeing mike as much as
seeing finn wolfhard but i thought this
brought me closer to that like i really
liked their scene together too of
confrontation her saying why why won't
you say that you love me and him
kind of insisting that he will but also
uh you know taking issue with her lies
and and the way in which she wouldn't
feel comfortable coming to him even
though she knows that there's a lot of
common ground and i think the the
distance they've driven between them
and the perspectives that they both
express feel natural and
not too contri like i feel like it would
be very easy to fall into contrivance
and since they are young characters who
are coming of age i feel like you know
these are written by adults and
sometimes the adults don't have as much
of that you know foothold in that walk
of life but i thought it was pretty
authentic here on both counts you know
well mike is
the first season with mike he he really
was like the lead kid of that of that
show
um
i don't know if he's like the definitive
lead character but i this is my favorite
season of mike is still the first season
and he was the one who was like more the
hopeful optimist and the kid you
identified with the most out of them all
and at least on an emotional standpoint
and he you know he saw eleven as the
only one who took real compassion upon
her
and as the students have progressed
they keep having these
moments of conflict with them of like
something about your attitude and the
way you're being like i don't like the
way you're being yeah you have to keep
having this recurring thing with him and
he just gets like defensive yeah like
upset and uh and
i i don't really i feel like the arc of
him is is not as like clearly defined
for me i would agree with that uh as but
he's always uh he's always a pleasant
presence but he's he doesn't really he
feels like definitely part more of the
ensemble now than he was initially as
like one of the main leads yeah you know
and
i don't know i just can't tell love and
he he loves what's up with the men in
this season just being like oh nancy i
don't know if i love you
or i do love you i can't tell you though
what i'm really doing and mike like i
can't write the word i could write a
whole letter but i can't write love mike
you know yeah and you can't even tell
her there just reassure her and it's
weird because like i believed him and so
i was like what's keeping you from just
go with that one step for clearly the
intent is there maybe it's when he lost
she lost her powers just wasn't the same
after that true love's kissing
infatuation that's right i only liked
you for your powers
now you're just like everyone else is a
girl here yeah yeah you just want me for
my wit
that was great i really like max's
performance or that actresses i really
think her performance has been very
solid interesting trajectory they're
doing it for her where
it's like the setup that they have for
each character here is you've got to
come to terms of your trauma to beat
these guys yeah to beat fact no you got
to come to terms
like how do i speed up acceptance
that's what life is like you know
identifying problems and going how do i
fast track myself to living functionally
really bold move they kill off max
i yeah and i mean i could definitely see
it being a big impactful thing
especially i mean you never know it
seems like this episode left off with a
pretty hefty it seems like the next
episode must focus pretty heavily on her
and what they're giving her is pretty
significant i think like those scenes
her scenes have been especially
affecting to me and so uh yeah i
it's funny i feel like we've got we
should have like a bingo card going or
like a betting pool going of who's gonna
die this we should have a deadpool for
who's gonna die in season four uh i
could see it for max i hope not but i
think they could do something really
powerful and impactful with that
i thought that they were jonathan and
what's the stoner guy saying argyle our
guy i thought they were pretty funny
this time around the most i enjoyed them
so far yeah
so this they're the steve of
uh california still waiting for
jonathan to
come like
something hefty to the plot yes see our
girls doing the heavy lifting
yeah i'm enjoying i enjoy them they're
more like funny comedic relief yeah and
it's
fascinating to me what they've done with
robin because i remember robin being
more of like
the cooler anti-social girl yeah
and this time around she just like
doesn't shut up yeah they're bringing
out her her geek her geek word vomiting
yeah
erotic it's very different from how she
was uh in the last season like she's not
like she was the one
with the scoops ahoy she was the one who
was like
she seemed smarter than them and was the
most level-headed and it was the coolest
one yeah
uh so to to have heard this time around
which is so neurotic
especially like any given situation just
doesn't know how to socialize
i don't know what it is maybe some
acting choices like i'm actually
attracted to nancy and here's why i'm
like being the way i am they keep making
me wonder about everyone's attractions
this season yeah it's like everyone's
going through relationship problems or
there's like a bunch of reasons to be
like wait are they vibing and are they
vibing
i don't know but yeah there's a sort of
a change
in robin but i'm curiou like i'm curious
to see if they if
if they're making a point out of that or
oria if it is just a choice but i liked
their little scene together and i
thought it was fun to get the yeah like
searching through the old newspapers and
figuring out that the shot in the dark
actually is like as much as that is
economics of time that they're like i
gotta do this quick research and then we
find out that was the right research to
do it still felt pretty nice and hopper
this episode like with everything uh in
russia and his buddy there and the whole
breaking his chains yeah like
i like how they've kept that like on
this very slow steady physical build
build-up because all certain things feel
very sort of fast-moving and very
intense
like you have this build with hopper to
this
probably very precarious escape of some
kind of sure yeah like they're able to
balance that too and just the the stuff
in russia is just so
desolate and so harsh like you could
really feel the bite of the cold and
everything
that's right they're in russia yeah
pilot in alaska yeah yeah okay get in my
mouth right you're confused with the
snow snow
snowy landscapes yeah yeah
but i don't know even that cannot go
according to planet course not it would
be terrible if you did yeah just like
polarizer shows
i got hop around don't even
in fact i'm gonna make his ankle even
better than it was before
working on a machine
it's called stem cell research and 3d
printing
yep all risers skeleton key for all
problems
all right guys well here we are stranger
things
um keep a lookout for our next reaction
and we will should chat with y'all soon
soon
olivier
haimlin yo thanks for being back here at
this point in time we're almost at a
million subs it's great to have people
like you showing your support and still
wanting these exclusive patreon day
shots and last time we talked about how
your first name meant olive tree which
is beautiful but we are looking up in
real time what your last name means
hamlin hamlin all right oh dang this is
crazier
check this out everyone okay the hamline
family lived in gluckersteia
uh their name however is a local
reference of old french derivation
it stems from the old french root hamel
indicating that the original bearer of
the name once worked at an outlying farm
which was dependent upon a main village
dude that is so cool
i understood all of that and all of that
relates to you
this is the freaking you're you're you
worked near someone's farm dude you're
an olive tree near a farm that someone
worked out and owns
man that's like a perfect progression
right there
you could be an olive farm that's how
bountiful you are
olivier hamelin
his name's french
olivier
but
no that's german uh but
i don't
i don't know if we could
the french don't like us hey we don't
have very many french viewers
i know there's a reason why yeah because
i have a real issue with french people
oh
i do too my issue is
i want to be just like all of them all
every french person they don't let me
and they every time you try to set foot
in the country
they don't let me appropriate yeah you
know well dude i tried
for the longest time i used to go by
ryan right here and then i tried to
change my name to frenchie
and they wouldn't they wouldn't want me
they wouldn't accept you i was like you
racist [ __ ] yeah
why can't i why can't i can't i identify
as french
i choose to identify as french
you're french to me i accept you i'm
romantic i got a big wee-wee like a
baguette it's like a bag
sticking out of a bicycle basket i
believe in free prostitutes yeah
absolutely that's what the french have
right free prostitute free prostitutes
is it weirdly it's really
totally contradictory
the charity process they get to write
off the time against their uh
you know french taxes
hello
i hope i can be accepted into your
french family and one day go by gregory
hamlin pull some strings bruh
you're a good guy you're a great guy
you should name a laboratory after you
or something or a farm in france
this went
so good
this went about as good as could be
expected
christina aguilera
[Music]